when i tell people i'm a pro football
player there's always a
look of like astonishment
i get laughter sometimes too but i don't
know there's tournaments for that
foosball yeah that's the one that's
that's what i do
foosball is not just a
bar room game it's a competitive sport
that's played at a professional level by
people all around the world
it's like a hand-to-hand combat you're
standing this close you know you're
standing three feet away from your
opponent and it's almost like you're in
a fight you're battling against each
other
i come from a long line of foosball
players
i got into foosball because of my dad
he played in the the golden era the
1970s when there was a million dollar
tour i've been playing for 20 years now
so for the first 10 to 12 years of my
career
i would practice on a table at home it
would be complete repetition over and
over and over
every player in here can execute a shot
or a pass but it's a matter of
constructing a solid game plan it's like
a
a game of chess on the mental side it's
it could be pretty taxing physically by
the end of the weekend
you're sore your hands are sore your
feet are sore so you have to be in
decent shape i always get a sweat band
on my arm just in case i get into a
heated match i get a
you know wipe my brow so
i go to
the world cup which is basically our
version of the olympics and i compete on
team usa
i do believe it should be in the
olympics
our only problem is the fact that
there's not a standardized foosball
table
and i'll do whatever it takes to
for the sport to reach that next level
bottom line is it makes me happy that
this is what i do and
yeah i love it
you